INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE DESIGNED
TO GAURN TUARANTEE EQUAL PROTECF
THE LAW.
>> THE TRIAL OF THREE MEN
CHARGED IN THE KILLING OF AHMAUD
ARBERY.
MARTIN SAVIDGE.
>> THE PROSECUTION RESTED ON
TUESDAY AFTER EIGHT DAYS AND 23
WENS.
THE DEFENSE RESTED AFTER TWO
DAYS AND SEVEN WITNESS E THE
PRIMARY ONE BEING, OF COURSE,
THE MAN WHO KILLED AHMAUD
ARBERY, TRAVIS McMICHAEL.
>> TRAVIS McMICHAEL TAKING THE
STAND IN HIS OWN DEFENSE FOR A
SECOND DAY IN THE TRIAL FOR THE
KILLING OF AHMAUD ARBERY.
LEAD PROSECUTOR CONTINUED TO GO
AFTER HIM DURING
CROSS-EXAMINATION.
>> YOU ALSO COULD HAVE STEPPED
AROUND THE BACK OF THE TRUCK AND
FOLLOWED HIM IN THE PATH THAT
WAY, IS THAT RIGHT?
>> YES, BUT THEN HE WOULD HAVE
OPEN, UNRESTRICTED RUN AROUND
THE TRUCK AND INTO MY OPEN DOOR
INTO MY PICKUP TRUCK, AND GET IN
THE TRUCK.
>> SO YOU'RE TELLING THIS JURY T
A MAN WHO HAS SPENT FIVE MINUTES
RUNNING AWAY FROM YOU IS
THINKING WILL WANT TO CONTINUE
TO ENGAGE WITH YOU, SOMEONE WITH
A SHOTGUN AND YOUR FATHER A MAN
WHO HAS JUST SAID STOP OR I'LL
BLOW YOUR [ BLEEP ] HEAD OFF BY
TRYING TO GET IN THEIR TRUCK?
>> THAT'S WHAT IT SHOWS, YES,
MA'AM.
>> THE PROSECUTOR ATTEMPTED TO
PURCHASE HOLES IN HIS TESTIMONY.
>> DETECTIVE SPECIFICALLY ASKED
YOU, DO YOU REMEMBER IF HE
GRABBED THE SHOTGUN AT ALL?
AND YOUR RESPONSE WAS I WANT TO
SAY HE DID, BUT HONESTLY I
CANNOT REMEMBER.
I MEAN, WE WERE -- ME AND HIM
WERE FACE TO FACE THE ENTIRE
TIME.
DO YOU REMEMBER SAYING THAT?
>> YES, AND I WAS TRYING TO
THINK OF THAT EXACT MOMENT,
TRYING TO GIVE HIM AS MUCH
DETAIL AS POSSIBLE UNDER THE
STRESS AND ALL OF THIS GOING ON.
IT WAS OBVIOUS THAT HE HAD THE
GUN FROM WHAT I WAS SAYING IN
HERE, HE HAD THE WEAPON THE WAY
THAT I WAS DESCRIBING IT.
HE DID NOT HAVE THE GUN AT THAT
SUCCESS I DON'T KNOW WHY.
>> ALSO PRESSURING HIM ON HIS
SELF-DEFENSE CLAIM.
>> AND YOU WERE RIGHT THERE AND
YOU JUST PULLED THAT TRIGGER
IMMEDIATELY.
>> NO, I WAS STRUCK, AND HE
WAS -- WE WERE FACE TO FACE AND
I WAS STRUCK AND THAT'S WHEN I
SHOT.
HE STARTED STRIKING, HE WAS ON
ME.
HE HAD A SHIRT OR SOMETHING TO
THAT POINT AND I HAD A GUN AND I
WAS TOO CLOSE TO DRAWING HIM.
>> HE'S STRIKING YOU.
YOU'VE GOT THE GUN UP IN THIS
THING AND YOU CAN'T DRAW DOWN ON
HIM AND IT'S A STRUGGLE AND HE'S
ON YOU AND YOU'RE GOING BACK AND
FORTH IN FRONT OF THE TRUCK, IS
THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING?
>> AND THE PROSECUTOR CALLING
OUT HIS AND HIS FATHER'S ALLEGED
INTENT TO MAKE A CITIZEN'S
ARREST.
>> URG DID YOUR STATEMENT TO THE
POLICE DID YOU SAY THAT YOU AND
YOUR FATHER WERE TRYING TO
ARREST MR. ARBERY, DID YOU?
>> NO, MA'AM.
>> MEANWHILE, OUTSIDE THE
COURTROOM PASTORS AL SHARPTON,
JESSE JACKSON, JAMAL BRIANCE,
MARTIN LUTHER KING III AND
ATTORNEYS BEN CRUMP AND LEE
MERIT JOINED THE ARBERY FAMILY
IN A PRAYER VIGIL LED BY AL
SHARPTON, JOINING A MARCH AFTER
WARDS TO HONOR ARBERY.
WILLIAM GOFF ATTORNEY FOR
WILLIAM "RODDIE" BRYAN, KEEPING
JESSE JACKSON OUT OF THE
COURTROOM.
THE JUDGE ONCE AGAIN DENIED THE
MOTION AND GOFF CALLED FOR A
MISTRIAL AFTER OBJECTING TO THIS
QUESTION FROM THE STATE.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT SOMEONE
STEALING IS DESERVING OF DEATH
PENALTY?
>> RELEVANCE, YOUR HONOR.
>> THE MISTRIAL REQUEST WAS
DENIED, BUT THE JUDGE ADMONISHED
THE PROSECUTOR AND INSTRUCTED
THE JURY TO DISREGARD THE
QUESTION.
BY THE END OF THE DAY, THE
DEFENSE RESTED THEIR CASE.
>> WITH THAT UNDERSTANDING, WE
REST.
>> AHMAUD ARBERY'S MOTHER
SOUNDED HOPEFUL AFTER COURT
ENDED FOR THE DAY.
S
I WANT TO REMIND YOU THAT THERE
WERE 74 DAYS THAT WE WENT
WITHOUT AN ARREST.
THINGS HAPPEN AND NOW WE'RE HERE
AND I AM VERY CONFIDENT THAT WE
WILL GET A GUILTY VERDICT.
VERY CONFIDENT.
>> MARTIN, WHAT'S N IN THE CASE?
>> WELL, TOMORROW THEY'LL GO
OVER THE CHARGING DOCUMENTS.
IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S JUST BASIC
BORING STUFF, BUT IT'S NOT.
THAT'S CRITICAL BECAUSE THOSE
ARE THE INSTRUCTIONS AND THAT'S
WHAT THE JURY IS GOING TO BE
TOLD ON THE CHARGES AND THEN THE
JURY COMES BACK MONDAY, 9:00
A.M. EXPECTING TO HEAR CLOSING
ARGUMENT, BUT AGAIN, IT'S NOT
YOUR TYPICAL CASE, THREE
DEFENDANTS.
THAT MEANS EACH GETS AN HOUR.
THREE HOURS FOR THE DEFENSE AND
THREE HOURS FOR THE PROSECUTION.
WE EXPECT THAT THE JURY WILL GET
THE CASE ON MONDAY, ANDERSON?
>> MARTIN SAVIDGE, APPRECIATE
IT.
JOINING US IS BISHOP REGINALD
JACKSON WITH THE EPISCOPAL
DISTRICT OF THE AME CHURCH.
HE IS ONE OF MANY CLERGY MEMBERS
OUTSIDE THE COURTHOUSE TODAY.
BISHOP JACKSON, THANKS FOR BEING
WITH US.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
PRAYER VIGIL THAT YOU ATTENDED
OUTSIDE THE COURTHOUSE TODAY.
WHY WAS IT IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO
BE THERE?
>> ANDERSON, FIRST, LET ME SAY
GOOD EVENING.
SECOND, THE PRAYER VIGIL TODAY
WAS AN AWESOME EXPERIENCE AND IT
WAS IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE THERE
BECAUSE THE BLACK CHURCH IN
PARTICULAR, THE BLACK PASTOR HAS
ALWAYS BEEN HISTORICALLY BEEN
THE CONSCIENCE OF THE NATION AND
BLACK PASTORS, WE STOOD WITH
ERIC GARDNER'S FAMILY IN NEW
YORK, WE STOOD WITH TAMIR RICE'S
FAMILY IN CLEVELAND AND WE STOOD
WITH THE FAMILY OF TRAYVON
MARTIN, AND WE STOOD WITH GEORGE
FLOYD AND WE ARE STANDING HERE
NOW WITH THE ARBERY FAMILY.
WE ENCOURAGE, WE DO ALL THAT WE
CAN TO LOVE AND HELP THEM KNOW
THAT THEY'RE NOT BY THEMSELVES,
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT TODAY.
>> YOU'VE SAID THAT YOU BELIEVE
THE DEFENSE'S CRITICISM OF BLACK
PASTORS BEING IN THE COURTROOM
WAS A LEGAL TACTIC ON THEIR
PART.
WHY DO YOU BELIEVE THAT AND WHAT
DO YOU THINK THEY WERE HOPING TO
A KEE
ACHIEVE WITH IT.
FIRST OF ALL, THE STATEMENT MADE
NO SENSE.
ONE DAY HE CRITICIZED REVEREND
SHARPTON FOR BEING THERE AND THE
NEXT DAY HE APOLOGIZED FOR THOSE
HE ALLEGEDLY OFFENDED AND THERE
WAS NO CONSISTENCE, IN ADDITION
TO THAT, WE BELIEVE THERE IS AN
ATTEMPT ON THEIR PART TO GET A
MISTRIAL AND HOPING THAT BLACK
PASTORS, I GUESS, WOULD ROAM
INTO THE COURTROOM AND
INTIMIDATE THE JURY AND THAT
KIND OF THING.
SO WE REALLY THINK THIS WAS A
LEGAL TACTIC THAT WE HAD NO
INTENTION OF WALKING INTO.
>> BENJAMIN CRUMP, WHO AS YOU
KNOW, IS THE ATTORNEY FOR AHMAUD
ARBERY'S FATHER IS LOOKED AT AS
A CRIMINAL OR THUG AND SOMEONE
LIKE KYLE RITTENHOUSE, WITH
FIRST-DEGREE INTENTIONAL
HOMICIDE IN WISCONSIN ATTRACTS
SUPPORT AND BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT.
I WONDER IF YOU AGREE WITH THAT,
HOW DOES THAT DISPARITY EVER GET
FIXED IN THIS COUNTRY?
>> WELL, I DO AGREE WITH WHAT HE
SAID AND THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS THIS HAS BEEN AN ONGOING
PROCESS, TRY TO CORRECT THAT
PERCEPTION, AND YET I'M NOT SURE
WHEN IT'S GOING TO END, AND I
THINK PERHAPS IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S COINCIDENTAL AND PERHAPS
SOMETHING THAT'S INTENTIONAL.
>> I DO THINK IT'S INTERESTING
THAT WHENEVER IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE IS A BLACKEN VOFLED WHO IS
A VICTIM.
THAT MAKES THEM LOOK NOT, AS IF
THEY'RE THE PERPETRATOR.
THIS BE GONE WITH AHMAUD ARBERY
AND FROM'S BLACK AFTER BLACK
AFTER BLACK.
WE SUPPORT ASK ENCOURAGE THESE
FAMILIES.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THE
JURY MAKEUP IN THIS CASE?
>> OH, IT'S IMPOSSIBLE NOT TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE JURY MAKEUP
WHEN YOU LOOK AT GLYNN COUNTY.
27% OF THE POPULATION AT LEAST
IS BLACK, YET THERE'S ONLY ONE
BLACK ON THE JURY, THAT RAISES
SOME TROUBLING CONCERNS AND EVEN
THE JUDGE HIMSELF RAISED AN
ISSUE IN TERMS OF RACISM PLAYING
A PART.
SO I DON'T THINK THAT CAN BE
DENIED, BUT YET WE'RE GOING TO
BE HOPEFUL THAT THIS JURY WILL
PAY ATTENTION TO THE FACTS AND
LET THE FACTS GUIDE THEM IN
MAKING THEIR DETERMINATION.
>> BISHOP JACKSON, I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME TONIGHT.
THANK YOU.
>> JOINING US IS PAUL ALLEN,
CRIMINAL DEFENSE ATTORNEY AND
FORMER PROSECUTOR, AS WELL.
FIRST OF ALL, THE MAKE OF THE
JURY.
THE DEFENSE WAS ABLE TO GET A
NUMBER OF POTENTIAL BLACK JURORS
STRICKEN FROM CONSIDERATION.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY WAS
SHOCKED BY THIS AND THEY SHOULD
BE BECAUSE WE LIKE JURIES TO BE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE COMMUNITY
AND IF YOU HAVE 30%
AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN THE
COMMUNITY YOU'D LIKE IT SEE THEM
FAIRLY REPRESENTED.
INSTEAD YOU ONLY HAVE ONE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN ON THIS JURY.
THE JUDGE, THOUGH, SAID THAT HE
HAD QUESTIONED THE DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS WHO EXERCISED THE
CHALLENGES KNOCKING THE BLACK
INDIVIDUALS OFF ABOUT THE
REASONS FOR THOSE CHALLENGES AND
THAT WHEN HE QUESTIONED THE
ATTORNEYS THEY EXPRESSED
LEGITIMATE REASONS FOR ASKING
THEM TO BE EXCUSED, SUCH AS THEY
KNEW TOO M